and this guy comes up to me and he's
like oh my God are you Tulsi freaking
gabbard he's like yeah so what are you
doing here there's nothing in Greensboro
it's like oh you know I'm here for this
event I'll be speaking out later on and
he's like you know what if I was on
Twitter right now I would be putting out
a tweet saying how much I don't like
Tulsi gabbard but now you're standing
right in front of me and I can't
freaking say that like you're a real
person and you know I ended up talking
to him for about five minutes or so and
he's like I gotta take a picture I was
like all right if you posted on Twitter
you better like be true to your word
here buddy and not not start talking
about me but it was just funny the
interaction which is exactly that like
in real life very rarely I've I've
actually had it happen a couple of times
where people will come up and say the
kinds of harsh you know mean criticisms
that they say on Twitter maybe all the
time but by and large most people
they wouldn't have that kind of
interaction with someone in real life